وصلنا قبل قليل لمدينه جنيف السويسريه
الهادئه لحضور حفل
جامبغيولوجي دي جانيف اي حفل الجائزه
الكبرى للصناعه الساعات هنا في جناب الذي
يقام في تياتخمو او مسرح الامو السويسري
العريق
الهدف الرئيسي لهذا الحدث هو تصديق الضوء
على اكثر الابداعات المعاصره تميزا
ومكافاتها سنويه والتعريف صناعه الساعات
السويسريه الدقيقه والعريقه وكذلك تكريم
اهم الساعات من حول العالم هيا بنا لنشاهد
وكما كل عام منذ اثنين وعشرين عاما اقيم
حفل توزيع جوائز كوم
بمدينه
صانع ساعات وتم عرض 90 ساعه المختاره
مسبقا لتشارك في الجائزه
لجنه التحكيم الخاصه هذا العام
صانع الالات والنحات وجائزه الاستثناء
الميكانيكي في صناعه الساعات الراقيه لدار
فاقدينو السويسريه العريقه اما جائزه
فكانت من نصيب درس ساعات تاج اما عن فئه
الساعات المرصعه بالمجوهرات فقد حصل الضار
بالكاري على الجائزه هذا العام لساعه 70
روزي
وتسلم الجائزه المدير العام
ولاده
تويتر
[موسيقى]
اعماس عن ساعه اخسو لتوفيا وكان الحضور
العربي جزء من حفل توزيع الجوائز هذا
العام اقامه هند صديقي المدير العام اسبوع
دبي الساعات عطور لجنه التحكيم بتسليم
للساعات اليابانيه العريقه
اليوم شوفوا كثير من الناس يقولون لكم ما
تحتاج الساعه اليوم لان عندك تلفون خلاص
تشوف الوقت على التليفون بس هذا مش صحيح
اليوم اذا انت تدخل المحلات الساعات ما
تلقى ستوكس في همم في المحلات لان في طلب
الساعات والساعات الكلاسيكيه اللي ممكن
الواحد يلبسها كل يوم يعني دائما فيها طلب
وبعدين احنا في في العالم العربي عندنا
الرجال والنساء يعني دائما باللبس
التقليدي الاكسسر الوحيد اللي ممكن انهم
يشاركون العالم في اللي هم ساعتهم
ومجوهرات المتشاركه العديد من صناع
الساعات السويسريه في لجنه تحكيم الجائزه
هذا العام الى جانب الايرلندي ادم كلايتون
عضو فرقه يوتيوب كما فازت دار اف ان انبي
بالجائزه الكبرى
او اقرب الساعات الذهبي
سويسرا
[موسيقى]